"You and I were meant to be
out here in the darkness.
That's who we are born to be."
Hey guys, Pete here. I just watched the Expanse
panel at New York City Comic Con 2021 and thought
I'd do a quick video to let you know what they said about the final season. they also dropped
a new trailer. it was a very final season sort of
don't give much away kind of teaser.
there was nomention if there would be something more
substantial to follow but either way i'll
come back and do a full breakdown of that after
i've had some time to look at it more closely.
so it is confirmed that season six will be six
episodes. they're gonna be airing them weekly.
it's gonna start on December 10th. the first
episode will come out then and then each one will
follow weekly until they get to the finale. just
one episode a week no mini binge at the beginning
so we have exactly six more weeks of the expanse
they did say that the final episode will be 65minutes
long and they said that was something that
they always wanted to do was end big. the panel was
like the other ones you've seen Dominique Tipper
did the hosting and then there were several cast
members and then the writers and the showrunner
so we had Steven Strait who plays Holden. Wes Chatham
who plays Amos. Shoreh [Aghdashloo] who plays Avasarala.
Nadine Nicole who plays Clarissa and Cara Gee
who plays Drummer. and then we had Naren Shankar
the showrunner. Ty Grank and Daniel Abraham the two
authors of the novels who produce and write for
the show. I thought it was interesting when they
were talking about going with six episodes no
one said that this was the idea that they had
in mind or this was something that they wanted to
do because they thought the story called for it.
they put an emphasis on how it was
much shorter than what they're used to
and Naren even said that it was difficult but
it gives it intensity and it really sets up for
an ending that's cathartic. Ty said they
had to stand on the gas pedal all the way
but then Daniel jumped in to say that he didn't
think they lost anything and he pointed out some
of the things that we've been talking about how
they pulled things forward to season five and
overall they sounded confident that they pulled
it off as far as what the cast had to say they all
felt like it was surreal that they were coming
to the end of their journey Bobbie [Frankie Adams] couldn't be
there because she was filming something else they
mentioned losing Alex and how that changes things
but didn't give any more details about how the
crew would be filled out instead each of them kind
of focused on where their character's at in the
beginning it sounds like things are pretty rough
steven strait said that morale is really low the
war is dragging on and there's a sense that they
haven't gotten anywhere it's wearing on holden and
the rest of the crew Naomi's angry about the part
that she played in alex's death that's hanging
over all of them no one seems to be happy that
clarissa is there except for amos and they're
flying around fighting with and killing belters
and as you can imagine that's hard for Naomi. Wes
Chatham brought up the fact that Amos used to use
these other people as his moral compass and now
he finds Clarissa doing the same thing with him
he's starting to make his own choices and not
necessarily questioning holden but wanting to
understand things on a deeper level it sounds
like there's a real sense of why do we have to
be in the middle of all this Nadine said that
Clarissa is just trying to keep her head down
and trying to prove her worth to these people who
she tried to kill they did hint that we'll see a
lot of the aftermath of the rocks falling on earth
and they phrased it in the way that earth gets
literally obliterated the ecosystem's breaking
down there's so many deaths and there's so many
other problems related to that and it's all on
Avasarala's shoulders she's lost her husband
and there seems to be a constant stress that it's
still not over and they don't know what to expect
charade did say that bobby and Avasarala get
to reunite she said they have a real connection
she sees herself and bobby and she can see the
qualities in her that other people can't and then
the cast interviews ended with Drummer and they
talked about how she's just basically floating
around with what's left of her family she's backed
into a corner with nowhere to go and everything's
pretty hopeless for her at the beginning she
doesn't really like earth she wants independence
for the belt but she doesn't like the free navy
either and she can't get on board with Marco
the idea of the protomolecule was brought
up and one of the more exciting things that
they confirmed was that they will be doing an
adaptation of strange dogs in the season they
said that would include showing more of laconia
and an idea of what the future will look like
later on in the story of course they didn't make
any announcements of future adaptations of books 7, 8,
and 9 so at least at this point it's just
what the future will look like but we may never
actually see that i think they tried to address
the idea of not being able to wrap that whole
story up they reinforced the idea that that's what
the later books are about they said that thing is
still there though how humans keep encountering
the proto-molecule and keep trying to make it into
what they want and daniel said tai describes it
as the rock against which people break themselves
so its presence will be felt but there will be
lingering mysteries at the end so not a whole lot
of surprises there if you're familiar with the
sixth book then you can probably map out what's
going to happen it is exciting and you see a bit
of it in the trailer that there's some Laconia
and some strange dogs it sounds like it's going to
be intense it sounds like it's going to be really
streamlined i hope that works well we've seen
them do that before six episodes is kind of a
disappointment but i have faith that they'll give
us something good i made a whole video about how
that might work so you can check that out and the
last thing they mentioned is that there's gonna be
short five to six minute segments that they're
going to be putting out in between episodes
so that'll be interesting to see what they do
with that like additional materials in between
and those were my big takeaways and i think that's
a good place to leave things like i said i'll be
back with the trailer breakdown soon and in the
meantime i'm curious to hear what you think about
the news in the comments let me know what you're
thinking we've got just about two months until
the first episode drops so what are you hoping to
see and they did change the release date for book
nine Leviathan Falls is going to be coming
out on november 30th rather than november
16th so we're going to get the end of the books
and then we're going to get the end of the tv
series in pretty close succession please like
this video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon